I got up early the next morning and I
just waiting for him to call me i mean i
sat there all day just pretty much just
waiting on that one phone call to make
sure that she was okay
suddenly there was a knock on the door I
open it up
when I saw the gun I realized that you
know anything could happen right now you
know this guy's never had a gun on him
before and here he is following me
around and that's when I first realized
that you know my Safety's really in in
jeopardy here I have no way I know this
guy could kill me tomorrow and nobody
knows really where I'm at he finally
calmed down a bit
you know after screaming for a while he
told me that they took him to the
airport she went inside she was supposed
to check in and pay her airport tax and
they come back out where they were gonna
take her back to the hotel and they were
gonna suit her up with the drug and then
take her back to the airport but they
said that she went into the airport and
they never saw her come back out they
didn't know where she was
my first thought was you know she just
got scared
and just got on the plane and just left
went back to Miami you know saved
herself I turn around until they kill
this dealer that you know it's his
problem they can't take off on him told
me you understand is your problem now
you got to go back to Miami with the
dress you said that you know people have
paid money for the drug in this part
went back and she went back with nothing
you know there's no telling what they
would do to us
he's got my plane ticket he has my
passport I have no money or a hotel
eat your life if you want to see your
country again now yeah then you have to
take these drugs you have to do it you
have a good job I felt that he could
just you know basically pull out the gun
shot me right there I mean there's
nothing to stop him
you understand oh I'm gonna have to take
these drugs on me this guy's basically
tell me I either take them or I'm never
going to see anything ever again you
know wants you to light it tomorrow I
really wanted to get back home so I
pretty much just had to agree and accept
it